How does adding more Lanes cause more traffic?
Take a city and a suburb. Between them is a
two-lane road a bike path and a train
line. Most people commute by bike or
train. The two-lane road is jammed every
day, so the city widens it to four lanes.
The road is no longer jammed. Now Karen and
her 50 friends can all take their kids to
school by car. Now a hundred rail commuters
can drive so they aren't dependent on train
schedules. Now 20 cyclists can drive because
it's faster. The four-lane road becomes jammed,
so the city widens it to six lanes. The road is
no longer jammed. Now 20 commuters can drive on
company fuel allowance instead of riding a
bike. Now a hundred rail commuters can drive
so they aren't dependent on train schedules. Now
50 high school students can drive instead of bike
or train because it's faster. Due to lower
ridership and revenue, the train line cuts
connections. Schedules become infrequent and
impractical, so 200 rail commuters switch from
train to car. The six lane road is jammed every
day, so the city widens it to eight lanes, and so
on until you have the Katy Freeway. And this is
how adding more Lanes only causes more traffic.